foreign
Tyson you're a personal astrophysicist
and of course host of StarTalk for this
episode we're doing something we've
never done before and might not ever do
it again uh first you might not know
that we have a patreon page where you
can support what we do and when you
become a patreon member basically become
a patron of StarTalk you give us the
latitude to experiment in many different
ways of bringing science down to earth
that's in part why we have so many
different vehicles
to do this so many different kinds of
programming that initially sponsors
don't they're a little afraid of it they
don't know if it'll work and so they
tend to be more conservative about the
risks than we want to be so patreon
support enables us empowers us to take
those risks well in this new tiering
system the entry level is five dollars a
month and it at last I checked I don't
think you can get out of Starbucks
without dropping five dollars so but who
am I to tell you how to spend your money
all right but four or five dollars what
you do is you get to ask exclusive
questions about the universe of me or
experts I bring in to address those
topics and these are exclusive sessions
only for patreon members it's a cosmic
queries just for you and what we're
gonna do this time is give you a taste
of what that has been at just at that
entry level there are other perks at
other higher level some are fun and
interesting and educational and there's
one category about autographed books and
I send them to you you know there's a
you can check it out okay but for this
episode what we've done is getting the
best of the patreon cosmic queries and
we put them together and I'm there
Fielding those questions with my comedic
co-host Chuck nice he reads me the
questions I've never seen the questions
before he reads them and we just have a
fun time riffing on what we know and
what we don't know about the universe
and so for this episode it is basically
our greatest hits and anyone can listen
to this episode previously it was only
available behind the paywall and so now
you'll get a taste of what will still
live behind the paywall and these are
exclusive questions and answers for
patreon members at that base level of
five dollars a month so let us begin
here I am with nice with the greatest
hits of patreon cosmic queries check it
out all right here we go this is a Bruno
Faria who says hello Dr Neil and Chuck
I'm Bruno from Brazil my question is
um the space is in constant growth does
that matter like planets and for us like
the space between our molecules or the
space between
atoms oh he's getting
Bruno thanks for that question so first
of all right now the expansion of space
is not strong enough on the scales of
solar systems and planets and moons for
that stretching to manifest okay to
reveal itself so but as this continues
what will happen is the stretching power
of the expanding universe will begin to
manifest on solar system scales and
planets will get separated from their
host stars and fly off into Oblivion
then eventually so it will begin to
overcome the gravity that's going on in
tight quarters then it'll begin to
overcome the electromagnetic forces and
it'll start separating atoms in the
molecules that they were once made of
then that'll continue and then start
interfering with the strong nuclear
force and then start separating atoms
and as that continues in 10 to the 20 no
in 20 billion years
if the stretching goes unchecked
it will reach a point where it will want
to stretch the very fabric of what cons
what comprises the space-time Continuum
the pixels the 3D pixels that construct
the universe in which we live it'll come
a point where those pixels cannot even
hold together and it wants to stretch
those but you can't stretch it any more
than you can stretch a fabric Beyond a
particular point and that what happens
at that point Chuck
it's the big rip so Bruno you just
described the Big Rip you just you just
laid the seeds of the Big Rip as this
stretching Force the this this it's
basically dark energy which continues to
overcome these other forces that are
trying to make life possible and yeah if
that goes unchecked that's that's the
end period And I lose sleep over what
that even looks like what that would be
like yeah well by the way that was a
painterly an eloquent description and I
love the 3D pixels of the universe that
is brilliant I don't know what else to
call them but that's what they are and
it's called a plank links it's called
named after Max Planck
yeah now plank length I've heard but 3D
pixels of the universe that's nah that's
beautiful I love that all right all
right here we go let's go Matthew power
oh really he's like a secret agent
um dear Neil and Chuck what's up why
does our solar system and many galaxies
seem to be disc like and not
atom-like with orbiting objects going
around in all manner of ways oh wow look
at that a person been thinking about
this yeah yeah because it's like a atom
has like a round nucleus so what about
our traditional representation of an
atom it's got you know the orbits in
every angle so let me use that as is I
iconographic reference yes to the atom
so a couple at first it's a brilliant
question it perplexed people for
centuries and the first indication that
maybe we were onto something was in the
mid 1700s like the literal exact mid
1700s 1750. two people independently
LaPlace a mathematician and uh the
philosopher uh what's the dude's name
it'll come to me in a minute uh they
both came up with what today we call the
nebular hypothesis okay Kant Emanuel
Kant oh and existentialist yeah exactly
exactly so so he did this on the side
and LaPlace sort of figured this out
because he knew some Physics but what
they were imagining was that if you had
a gas cloud
because there's gas all over the Galaxy
and if that's what you make stuff out of
all right how might that happen so if a
gas is kind of rarefied and thin so you
got to sort of collapse it so that it
can become solid stuff okay so as the
gas cow Cloud begins to collapse what
they knew
was that however slowly
it's rotating as a large gas cloud as it
gets smaller it will rotate faster
just like the ice skater who brings in
the arms right they begin to rotate
faster okay well as you rotate faster
there's this centrifugal force that
prevents things from continuing to
collapse
in that
disc Direction because that's where the
centrifugal forces are preventing it but
if you come in from the top and bottom
they know it's centrifugal force
preventing you so you collapse like a
pancake keeping the flat shape and this
would be a very natural thing to happen
in the universe and sure enough that's
how you get flat galaxies and our galaxy
is flat spot other spiral galaxies are
flat and they're really flat and they
say how flat are they have flat artist
thank you for asking that uh so are they
as flat as a pancake no they're flatter
flat as a crepe they're like a crepe or
or tortilla yes I don't want to be
French or you want to be uh Mexican yeah
so they're our Milky Way is about a
hundred times as wide as a cross as it
is thick
and that's way thinner than a pancake
yeah that's paper it's practically paper
right so so you get these shapes when
that happens so what happens to the
Galaxy it happens to the solar system
within the Galaxy right so this is a
very natural phenomenon now let's say
you don't participate in that collapse
okay you're so far away you don't care
what anybody close up is doing well you
still might form things but you're not
going to be in a disc oh my gosh let's
look far out in our galaxy there's what
we call the ort cloud of comets it's not
a literal cloud of of diffuse matter
it's just clap it's comets filling a
space that completely surrounds the Sun
and so we call that a cloud rather than
a belt
because belts are flat like the asteroid
belt right hyper belt right these are
belts that are flat and they go around
the Sun in the plane of the solar system
you go far enough out so those comets
come in from Every Which Way Around this
solar system so they do represent a
spherical uh distribution of of icy
bodies if the Comets that come from the
orange Cloud they're very long periods
like the hundreds the tens and hundreds
of thousands of years because it's very
far out for them to make their complete
Loop and so so it's a great question we
think we got that one solved and by the
way all discs are made that way so the
what are called accretion disk the discs
that form around black holes yeah it's a
general phenomenon in the Galaxy so let
me ask you this thing oh by the way and
people in their middle age who gain
weight around their belt in my field we
would joke and say you have an accretion
too
well that sounds a lot better than a
beer pot belly beer belly pot belly yeah
right I haven't creation this I have an
accretion disc yes no you're fat
so the spinning can happen in any
direction first to create the flat
because there's going to be one that's a
great question there's going to be one
orientation that dominates that's what
I'm saying because because the cloud
cannot spin in all directions at once
right because it would it would collide
with itself like two marshmallows hot
marshmallows hitting they Collide and
attach and so that stuff settles out and
it finds the dominant axis around which
to rotate so is that why you can look
out and see galaxies in different
positions yeah so that so the the spiral
galaxies can be face on edge right and
you get to see all of no no they'll form
wherever their gas cloud their native
gas cloud whatever that orientation was
but now here's something suppose you
formed stuff
suppose you formed your stars before the
gas collapsed to the middle
wait a minute then you're not going to
get a disc right
because they'll orbit around the center
but they're not going to collapse and
stick to itself so we it's such a Galaxy
does a gift they're called elliptical
galaxies these are fully sort of puffed
up three-dimensional spherical
elliptical shapes and they have very low
gas there's no gas making that disc
happen so we know it must be lovely at a
party
gas free
so so we know that the planets of the
solar system all formed after the gas of
the solar system had collapsed wow the
hyper the the Oort cloud of comets those
formed after okay and they did not form
out of uh they did not require the
collapsing gas cloud to form and so
they're still in there in their atomic
orbits around the Sun so it's a great
question so Andrea or Andrea sparini
says this hello Neil and Chuck if I were
an astronaut floating in Intergalactic
space
and I could remove all matter from the
visible universe
where would I be
and what would my eyes be able to see if
the boundaries of the universe would
wrap around my body thanks for helping
me on my long walks with your podcast my
long walks to the edge of the universe
yeah don't walk too far yeah don't walk
too far girl hold on I'm talking about
where would you be with no matter at all
so generally where you are only has
meaning in reference to something else
right so there's an interesting
philosophical dilemma right so if I we
are a certain number of degrees west
of the Greenwich Prime Meridian and
where a certain number of degrees north
of the equator all right so we're
basically like 74 degrees west 41
degrees north
that so that's where we are on Earth's
surface relative to a coordinates that
have been pre-established okay but then
where are those coordinates
all right so the Prime Meridian is like
zero and so so
where are those in relationship to
anything else we can say that there's 74
degrees east of us but that would make
us the preeminent Prime you know
establisher of the coordinate system but
we know we're not
so at some point you have to arbitrarily
declare the coordinate system
and then reference everything else to it
and everyone then has to agree that
you've done that otherwise people don't
know where they are relative to each
other
all right you you know where you are
relative to some grid that you set up in
your backyard and somebody else set up
some other grid and you will never
communicate accurately uh with each
other or productively so everybody's got
to agree so the prime meridian was
established by International agreement
okay to go by the way it almost went
through Paris the Paris Observatory uh
France was bucking for the prime
meridian back when it was up for grabs
and uh England won out
it's rumored that France conceded the
prime meridian uh in exchange for
everybody adopting the metric system
so because they came up with the metric
system so this is
yeah the quid pro quo of historical
science and metrics but anyhow so if you
are if you are between galaxies and
galaxies are the things that dot the
observable universe and then you start
removing the galaxies yet you have no
coordinate system
but what you will know because we kind
of know this is that you are still
nonetheless in the center of your own
Horizon
but you can't see the edge of your
horizon because there's nothing to allow
you to measure it so
and by the way we think of Horizons as
two Dimensions like out at C but in
space Your Horizon is all around you
right in every direction so it's a
spherical Horizon and by the way yeah
it's confusing disoriented and you want
to talk about your wife getting mad
because you don't ask for directions
now you get lost in all three dimensions
now you're lost enough depresses at once
am I up down left right north south
before or backwards uh so so yeah
so yeah so there's no there's if there's
no coordinate system established uh it
doesn't make sense to say where you are
other than to say you're at the center
of your own Horizon which isn't very
helpful
but then again do you really need to
know where you are if there's no place
to go
oh snap
look at that that is that has been my
life for an entire year now no place to
go I spent my whole life for a year now
I don't care where my current
coordinates are because I have no
coordinates I need to visit that's it
that's a profound I'm not going anywhere
that's the problem but even if you were
you're not
even if you pick a direction you're not
headed anywhere that's right right yeah
because there's no place waiting for you
it's all been removed from the universe
bye Andreas yeah Andre I got to tell you
this got really sad very quickly got a
sad fast it's that sad fast
oh by the way but it is true if you're
navigating within the Galaxy you're not
going to be using GPS on Earth so we're
thinking in the future as we move
throughout the Milky Way We would set up
a grid system targeting pulsars that are
scattered because they're very fast
rotating and they said radio pulses in
for having rotated in in their
configuration and that gives you a place
to look and you can get a timing system
based on that and a system of locations
within the Galaxy much like GPS on Earth
so Pulsar GPS is going to be the few
future space travel wow that's cool all
right let's get more questions I'm going
to take a quick break but when we return
we will continue to dig in deep to our
patreon exclusive question and answer
archive
with Chuck Nice
we'll be back in a moment
welcome back to Star Talk this episode
is a collection of cosmic queries asked
by our patreon patrons we reached back
into the archives of our monthly patreon
only episodes to find some of our
favorite moments of
questions and answers to share with you
so let's find out what Chuck asks me
next
fed To Us by our patreon members
yeah well let's start at the top here
this is Denny
Denny is saying greetings from Germany
um it says I wonder why so many people
believe the aliens will fly in a disc
shaped ship is there any physical
advantage in building aircrafts in that
shape
no next question
it's like no right no yeah we've got
this Trope in our head right and and
once it once the seed gets planted it's
kind of hard to shake it and so so I I
remember do you remember the show Lost
in Space of course okay I think we
talked about this once where you know
these the spacecraft only sort of
levitate when they rotate right right
like they're rotating discs right but
there they are on the ship looking out a
window at the same destination even
though the whole thing is rotating
that very much Disturbed me
okay
so basically why is everything just
whizzing by left and right and so yeah
it just doesn't there's I mean yes a
disc has nice aerodynamics okay but of
most of a journey through space has no
air so it doesn't have to be aerodynamic
at all really uh so there's a lot of
there's a lot of problems with that
shape that's why my favorite my favorite
spaceship
um in all of sci-fi is the Borg ship
from uh Star Trek uh which is a giant
Cube the most aerodynamic thing there it
is there they said you know we got this
we don't need to
we don't need to be Sleek we don't need
to be in that same vein the Enterprise
didn't have to be that aerodynamic
looking right because it was never in
the atmosphere it was always out out in
the out in the empty space yeah so
that's a great question and I in my
whole life I have not found any
legitimate aerodynamic reason or any
other reason to design a ship that way
by the way there's a little bit of
physics that people don't you know if
you're just making up stories you
typically miss it if you are in open
space
and you set something rotating in One
Direction uh-huh
something has to go rotating in the
exact opposite way to counter balance
that so in other words if it starts not
rotating
and then begins to rotate something
inside of it has to rotate the opposite
way to cancel out what's called the
angular momentum if you have a flying
saucer that's just there floating
it has zero rotational angular momentum
okay I was just redundant there zero
angular momentum okay zero
so if any part of it starts rotating
in One Direction
some part of it has to rotate the
opposite way to cancel out the angular
momentum
because you can't just set yourself into
into rotational motion unless you have
rocket Little Rocket Vector right yeah
and then you see you're spewing out
gases in One Direction and that's the
maintains the momentum so to see these
spec these these in all these sci-fi
things they just rotate no it's
violating deep laws of physics laws of
physics that no alien is going to
circumvent and the funny thing is you
see them rotating and like you say
there's if there's zero reason for it
whatsoever
there's absolutely no reason for it but
imagine it imagine a 747 say okay we'll
start rotating now right for what for
what it's like like you don't fly and
barrel roll your way all over to Europe
exactly you know there's no reason to
barrel roll the plane the entire way
you're going to Europe it's stupid
exactly exactly so wow anyhow all right
that was cool man yeah great question
okay here we go watch this watch this uh
this is Elaine and the Stars says hey Dr
Tyson Lord nice can a moon
have a moon
oh I I like the I just love the whole
you know positioning of that can a moon
have a moon
yes
yes you sound very skeptical when you
say that yes yeah yes it's very suspect
meal you got it's got to be very zonal
okay so the first moon has to be far
enough away from the main planet
so that the moon around the moon when it
orbits around is not badly affected when
it's on the near side compared to the
far side right okay you got to make sure
your orbits can stabilize out because
orbital Allegiance can get very
complicated if you have three objects
okay it's called the three body problem
and it's very it's it's basically
chaotic the three body problem except in
very restricted cases so so in other
words the sun earth and moon is a three
body problem
but we're so far the hell away from the
Sun
that our moon can hang out here without
thinking oh my gosh now I have to go
hang out and orbit the sun right it
doesn't have orbital Allegiance problems
if Earth were orbiting much closer to
the sun right then the moon as it comes
around the back side or the front side
will say hey the sun is tugging me more
than you are Earth that's right I'm
gonna go that way and then it
destabilizes everything so the
consequences of destabilized orbits is
you'll fall into the Sun or you'll fall
into the main planet or you'll get
ejected forever
we think the solar system started with
at least 30 planets when it originally
formed and it was just a jockeying force
stable orbits and not everybody wins
that that
contests yeah What You Won't Do for your
moon some other planets gravity it's
gonna take it taken off just better
remember that
girl you don't let him treat you like
that girl you're gonna let him treat you
like that
switching my allegiance
everything
so yeah so moons can have moons in the
same way if you think of Earth as a moon
to the sun we have a moon you know if
you can think about it that way so it's
really the three body problem there you
go yeah and orbits tend to be highly
unstable
so
and by the way you can invert that and
say uh you can have double star systems
such as what was portrayed in the first
of the Star Wars movies which is of
course Star Wars episode four okay
and he walks out he's on the sand planet
or whatever and he sees a double Sunset
all right that's that's the only
accurate science in the entire Star Wars
series
[Laughter]
soundtrack by Chuck Nice
I felt like you needed a little a little
Star Wars music bed for that everybody
that's an iconic scene by the way a long
time ago in the galaxy far far away far
away so in other words those two stars
are orbiting close to each other right
and the planet is orbiting much farther
away
right so that's the inversion of this
problem you can have two main bodies
right but they have to be far away and
close to each other so that as you orbit
them you don't know that one is closer
to you than the other because they're
sort of it's a smoothed out sort of
gravity field but the moment those two
stars are far apart or you orbit close
to them
forget it you're in an unstable
situation there you go awesome here we
go let's go to TJ Monroe
TJ says this Dr Tyson now this is TJ
speaking here okay got nothing to do
with this you're pre-disassociating
yourself I am pre-disociated okay all
right uh Dr Tyson
he's a graviton
there you go
thanks TJ okay
graviton is a proposed Quantum particle
of gravity
they've yet to be detected so it's is is
it a graviton is to gravity
gravitational waves what a photon is to
light waves wow
all right so we we think of light as
waves and it moves through space right
and that's fine okay and you can measure
them as waves depending on your
apparatus but you can also measure it as
photons right provided you have the
right apparatus and when you do you have
concluded and demonstrated that light
behaves both as a particle as a wave and
as a particle both of them okay we have
already measured gravitational waves
all right from colliding black holes The
ligo Observatory laser interferometer
gravitational Observatory that measured
waves so do we have an apparatus yet
that can measure the quantum particle
that gravity represents and we don't but
we're not given reason to think it
wouldn't exist so it's out there it's
dangling above our heads maybe it
doesn't exist and if it doesn't that
would be interesting too
so the graviton is the force propagator
of gravity in the way that the photon is
the force propagator of electromagnetic
energy in the way that the gluon is the
force propagator of the strong force
and in the way the intermediate Vector
boson is these is the
is the force propagator of the weak
Force so all four forces have a an on
photon boson
um gluon gluon and a and a graviton
there it is there you go simple there
you go there you have it so add that to
your stick on
[Laughter]
hopefully that clears some things up for
you
all right all right here we go this is
Kevin The semelier Who uh is also a
friend if you weren't the director Kevin
recommend a wine next time we told you
this that's right Kevin
yeah if you don't recommend a wine you
know I don't know we have to part ways
okay okay there you go Kevin The
Gauntlet has been thrown down you must
recommend the line next time all right
next time Kevin says this if you weren't
the director of the Hayden planetarium
what do you think you would be doing
oh oh and this is a question to a man
who knew when he was like nine years old
that he was going to be an
astrophysicist so that's a damn good
question okay so I have a cop-out answer
and that is if I didn't spend so much
time thinking about how other people
learn and how they think and what brings
joy to them about the Universe I would
just be an astrophysicist unheard of in
a lab somewhere and you would never know
my name because no one would come to me
for sound bites no you don't get to do
that no yeah that's yes
can't be an astrophysicist still okay
okay something else okay he said he said
director of the planetarium what else
would I be and I said I'd be hidden in a
lab somewhere but you still be an
astrophysicist
this has to be another Universe it
wouldn't happen in this universe okay
I'd be I'd be a a songwriter for
Broadway musicals oh now that that go
putting word to page and putting a rhyme
that's simple and two people fall in
love and they're so com this they're so
overrun by that emotion that they have
to stop and sing a song about it oh my
God
by Neil deGrasse Tyson don't you love
the night sky
the reason why they have to be in
another universe is because I don't know
how to sing and I don't know how to
write music okay so that's a that's a
whole other Universe a parallel a
parallel verse that's cool that I'd have
to do that in but thanks for that
question Mr Soma we're going to take
another quick break but when we return
more patreon only Cosmic queries that
have never before have been posted
Beyond The Exclusive patreon page
welcome back to the special edition of
cosmic queries and before we bring you
to the third and final segment let me
just remind you that these Cosmic
queries were mined from years of patreon
exclusive content
that were Cosmic queries sent in by them
and answered and kept behind a paywall
for their own access and we are bringing
that across the Divide so you can get a
taste of what an entry-level patreon
membership will bring you at five
dollars a month
so picking up on the greatest hits of
cosmic queries
here's Chuck and me
doing our best to answer some of the
coolest craziest wacky questions on the
internet Eric Varga says this hey Chuck
hey Neil just observing the stars in our
galaxy we know that most solar systems
are binary could it have been possible
in the early formation of our solar
system that we used to have two sons and
that our sun kicked out another star
from our system like an evil twin or a
wife kicking out a husband after an
argument that is not in the that is
not how did you know that yes how the
hell did you know that that I put that
in there that's okay so Chuck go back
out to the front lawn and bring your
clothes back in and your stereo system
I don't need to know all your business
yes and also could life have evolved on
Earth if we did have two sons okay yeah
so so let me let me sharpen what they
said most stars in the night sky when
you take a telescope to them will reveal
more than one star in mutual orbit right
so more than half the stars are double
multiple star systems sweet turns out
planetary orbits are not particularly
stable under those conditions and
because they're they're gravitational
Allegiance gets challenged every time
are you too close to one or too far from
the other come on over here no come on
over here exactly over here no come on
over here exactly and so so though you
can get chaotic orbits and even unstable
orbits and they'll fly away so we expect
the most stable systems of planets to be
happily orbiting single stars but it is
possible to have two stars orbiting so
close together and you the planet
orbiting far enough away
that there's a smeared common gravity
between the two and you don't feel this
competing Allegiance okay so you can
construct a a star system where that's
the case and that's what was in Star
Wars episode four
um the great hope or the hope the Hope
Diamond what's the name of that yeah New
Hope the New Hope the New Hope the New
Hope A New Hope the episode four where
Luke is out as he's in the sand Planet
wherever and there's a double Sunset
thing yes I want you to notice that
those stars are not far apart from each
other they're near each other on the sky
so that planet he was on can sustain a
stable orbit around it and you can
evolve life and have everything that you
would want and need and that is the only
correct science in All Star Wars movies
combined damn damn oh I'm just saying
not even not even the bar scene come on
[Laughter]
so there's nothing wrong with having two
stars as long as you're not
gravitationally disturbed by it
um not a problem at all and yeah it'd be
fun you have double sunsets and you have
two Shadows but often the other sun is
filling in the shadow that would be made
by one of the Suns so you're not gonna
have two distinct Shadows
um uh coming out from you the way you do
on Broadway when you have two collimated
beams of light you can get two distinct
Shadows there
um because the light is only going in
One Direction and you have a dark place
and a light place around it in on if
it's two suns it's shown in light
everywhere so you're not going to get
beautiful double Shadows but you get
double sunsets those will be those are
twice as romantic sweet okay this is
Gabriella
uh this cops I I think they're making
this crap up now
d-i-j k h o f f z so uh
these cops okay hey Gabriella here's the
deal
um no no Gabby go again just shorten the
whole damn thing oh by the way I can't
believe you said that because I just
looked and she ends it thanks Gabby okay
all right she goes hey Neil Chuck happy
New Year what do we know about any plans
for an Alpha Centauri related Expedition
manned or unmanned so just to remind
people Alpha Centurion is the closest
star system to the sun four light years
away all right for the so that's that's
in our backyard cosmically speaking so
your answer is none no wait wait so four
light years at the fastest we have ever
sent a spaceship
would take anywhere between 15 and 30
000 years to get there okay to get to
the closest star system and Alpha
century is visible primarily from the
southern hemisphere you can catch it if
you go as far south there's like Florida
I if I remember its location but
everybody in the southern hemisphere can
see it it's a relatively bright star
it's bright because it's nearby more
than because it's intrinsically bright
and notice I call it a star system
um it was named out for Centurion
because it's the brightest
star in the constellation Centaurus okay
and so for many not many constellations
we see the stars and you you just in the
old days today we would do it
differently but
um Alpha Beta Gamma Delta Epsilon this
sort of thing that's why Star Trek has
you know Alpha set E5 or something or
whatever there would be Alpha City would
be the brightest star in the
constellation cetus and five would be
the fifth planet in that star system so
there's a coding so Star Trek was like
first out of the box to try to create a
lexicon for planets and Planet types but
anyhow so Alpha Centauri we know is a
star system
okay and so there's it's a multiple star
system
and the nearest star in that star system
is called Proxima Century I wonder why
okay
is it proximal to us is it right right
okay so that star
was recently discovered to have an
exoplanet
and that's Proxima B
okay a would be the main star we we
letter them by all the objects in the
system
um and a is the star B is the the planet
so Proxima B is an exoplanet uh it's
earth size sort of you know so so it we
fortuitously the nearest star system the
nearest star of the nearest star system
has a planet that's Earth-like
so yeah that'd be the first one we'd
visit if we were to go anywhere and uh
can you we have to kind of live forever
for that to happen and you have to
convince someone would you like to spend
70 000 years of or thirty thousand years
of living Forever on a ship headed
towards a planet we don't know anything
about
all right and and why which what and you
or have make it a generational ship and
you have babies and then 12 General
a thousand Generations later uh they'll
get there and they'll wonder why the
hell they've got sent in the first place
or just get or just invent light travel
light speed travel
four years and that'll take four years
correct or or invent warp speed travel
and then you get there faster than light
or 15 minutes or or invent wormholes and
then just step through a portal and you
come out on the other side seconds later
so so yeah so there's no plans because
we don't know how to do anything faster
than chemical rockets at the moment
there is this something called project
star shot which are these micro
satellites they're the size of a postage
stamp and you can cram all kinds of
electronics on something that's small
these days like like
um radio transmissions and and
gyroscopic stabilize and power sources
because you can have a little solar
panel thing that all right so
there's a plan to have a boatload of
these
launch them into space have them open up
a solar sail a light sail
all right now this is a little it's like
a sale and then have a set of lasers
from Earth beam to these sales and
accelerate them towards Alpha century
if you do the calculation right and the
sales are large enough and the power of
the laser is big enough the lasers will
impart an Impulse into these craft it
will accelerate them to 20 percent the
speed of light
of course the farther away they get the
weaker is the light signal so this is
all factored in look at their 20 the
speed of light which means they'll get
there in 20 years right if you're one
fifth of speed of light and you're four
light years away do the math it's 20
years all right so and then they would
beam signals back to us at the speed of
light that takes four years so we could
actually have an entire mission
that unfolds over a 24 year period
and but the problem is you know you can
do that because they're very light
you know light as in they don't have
much mass whereas you know why can't we
do that to people because you
people weigh too much we just know we
just sent a bunch of jockeys
we just send jockeys yeah I think that'd
be even lighter Chuck than John okay
yeah yeah I imagine jockey's like
strapped to solar sales and then
yeah
I think the jockey Union would object I
I think but all right you know also are
tiny people out there are coxins for uh
rowing
the cocktail used to row so if they
don't take up wait in the boat yeah I
was a heavyweight boat so uh odd it was
called a heavyweight boat because I was
40 pounds lighter to row in it than than
I am in this moment but we we all we're
all the biggest guys you know I was six
296 pounds and I was one of the littlest
guys on the boat
um I wrote stroke which is the person
who sits right in front of the cockson
who can't see any other rowers so if I
can't see any other rowers you have to
do what I do because that's all they
could look at that's all they can look
at right so
um and the coxin is
um
uh you know someone who's usually barely
five feet tall
six to 195 and you're the smallest guy
in the boat what was this like a a a
viking a rose ship was there a God was
the Cox in a guy with a drum just like
um
we we had a a uh a Norwegian guy in the
middle of the boat the middle four seats
it's called the engine room four out of
the eight seats wow and he was six five
uh probably 2 25 230. that's crazy I can
I'll find a picture and I'll show you me
standing next to in another and we'll
find another excuse to to show that
maybe when we do the physics of rowing
I'll pull out one of my rowing pictures
on the metal stands got a gold medal in
that race
um anyhow that was just one question
well here's here's one here's one that's
a little more personal that you'll help
someone with and this is the artist
formerly known as James Smith
um hey Neil and I guess Chuck uh well he
doesn't always know that you're going to
beat a guy but yeah okay and so he goes
I'm 37 from Indianapolis and I have been
wanting to return to school I really
love math and science is it too late for
me to get into astrophysics or astronomy
or I have the Sans of time just run out
on my Cosmic scholarly Journey thank you
so much for all you guys do love James
okay
we're gonna have to end with this
question it's a great question so here
you go what I have come to learn James
is that as human life expectancy
increases
the cutoff times also go up with it if
there's a cut of time time for anything
so there was a day when you know you you
know why was the retirement age put at
65 because that's when most people died
go look at this genius okay let's let's
go go look at the Actuarial tables from
the 1930s whenever they could have a
65-year retirement age we were dying
between 65 and 70. it's great they're
gonna collect on the insurance right so
so that that's how that played out all
right and now people are not even
retired they're not leaving the job
until they're 75. look at old movies how
old was the person they considered old
sitting in the corner that person was in
their 60s
and at most 70. all right I've watched
old Twilight Zone episodes black and
white from the 50s and 60s and the old
person the really old person in the
nursing home is 72. so
all I'm saying is
50 years ago used to be given up for
debt at 72 and now you can go to 85.
um if you're 37 you've got at least
another 40 years that takes you to 70 40
years
40 years look what people do between
high school and graduate school to get
Advanced degrees they do that and then
they're on the market by the time
they're 30. you got plenty of years to
do this just do it don't let anybody
stop you and we'll welcome you on the
other side wow and Chuck I don't want to
find your name in that list of patreon
members no oh no that's a good deal
don't even I'm signing up right now
all right thank Chuck this is uh Star
Talk Cosmic queries
patreon Edition Neil deGrasse Tyson keep
looking up
[Music]